The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
So, we continue our discussion
of quantum states of light,
and we focus on single
photons as qubits today.
But before I get
into this, I want
to ask you if you have any
questions about the last unit
we be completed on Wednesday--
namely, the discussion or non
classical light-- in
particular, squeezing light--
and we also discussed a lot
of exciting quantum mechanical
effects related
to beam splitters.
So, any questions?
Anything you would
like to see discussed?
So, as I pointed out,
we want to now talk
about realization of quantum
logic and quantum gates
with single photons, but I
also said that we are actually
using the language of
quantum communications--
a kind of information
processing to describe
general physics in
a very nice way.
So, first-- when we
talk about photons,
we should talk about our
qubits, and right now, you
may think that having
a single photon
and having no photon in a
mode are two possibilities.
And you could use
them as qubits.
However, I will tell you today
that it is better, actually,
to use always one photon, but in
two different wave guides-- two
different modes.
But, we'll get
there in a moment.
So, the first task at hand is
we want to manipulate photons.
And for that, I want to
introduce phase shifters
and beam splitters.
And just to give you the
punchline right away,
what I want to show you is that
those two simple devices --
beam splitter, a half-silvered
mirror, a phase shifter,
which is just a piece of glass
which you can put into one
of the laser beams-- that those
two elements and those two
basic operations, if they
are now put together--
if you do a beam
splitter, a phase shifter,
another beam splitter and such--
you can realize any single
qubit operation.
Therefore, if you have
our qubit cubic state
with single photons, any
possible state of those qubit
can be realized using
these optical elements.
Therefore, when I say we want
to realize how we can manipulate
photons with optical
elements and such,
I'm not going for a zoo
of optical elements.
Those two will do it all.
So, with the phase
shifter, that's
what we discussed at
the end of last class.
If you have two modes, and
we shift the phase in one
of the modes, just simply
put a piece of glass into it,
then there is a phase shift.
And why do we need two modes?
Well, phases are
usually-- at least
in experiments-- not
absolutely defined.
You need a phase
reference, and here,
the mode a acts as
a phase reference.
Let me address one question
which a student asked me
after class, and
this was related
to what phases appear
in more than one place.
The student's
question was motivated
that if you have one
photon, it's a flux state.
A flux state is a circle
in the causal probability,
and therefore, the electric
field has no phase.
Well, this is the phase
of the electric field,
but here, we're talking about
the phase of the wave function.
And a flux state within
photons is an eigenstate
of the harmonic oscillator.
It has a time dependence,
e to the i omega t,
and we can change its phase.
So, this is a kind of phase
shift I've introduced here.
So, the second element
we need to realize--
arbitrary single qubit
operation is the beam splitter,
and I introduced a beam splitter
by just saying, hey look,
I think that's a
good Hamiltonian.
Let's see what this Hamiltonian
does to the two modes,
and then we realize-- yes,
it takes those two modes,
and it mixes the modes with
cosine theta sine theta reading
factors.
That's exactly what you
expect a beam splitter to do.
I'm not sure we need
here now because it's
part of your
homework assignment.
You will show that if you
have a coherent state,
the coherent state is
split by a ratio which
is cosine square theta
sine square theta.
So, it's exactly what you'd
expect from a beam splitter.
So from that, you
realize now what
this angle theta is, which I
just put into the Hamiltonian.
The cosine square
and sine square of it
is the reflection
and the transmission
of the beam splitter.
Any questions at that point?
Let me now introduce
matrix representation,
which will come in handy.
You remember that you transform
an operator-- the mode
operator, the annihilation
operator a and b.
We multiply with the beam
splitter operator on the left
and on the right,
b dega-- b ab dega.
But there is often a simpler
way how the right inside
can be written, and this is by
using a matrix representation,
which goes as follows.
We can say that the two
operators are transformed
by the following
matrix, and this matrix
represents the beam splitter.
So that's what the beam splitter
does to the mode operators.
Now, we want to talk about
what does the beam splitter do
to quantum states, to
single photon states.
So now, we want to transform
the single photon states.
It's a little bit
like, well-- we
know what to do in
the Heisenberg picture
to the operator,
but now, we want
to see what happens
to the wave functions.
So, now-- I want to
say it very slowly,
because it shouldn't lead
to any confusion later.
We have single photons-- we can
have the single photon in mode
b, or we can have it in mode a.
These are the two possibilities.
And right now, I
label it like this--
where the first number is your
occupation number of mode a,
and the second number is
your occupation in mode b.
You have to be a
little bit careful--
I'm just saying that keep
your alert level high.
Later, I will use
qubit representation,
where the qubit one means
the photon is in mode a,
and the qubit zero means
the photon is in mode b.
So when we talked about logical
states of our two levels used,
and the photon can be here
or the photon can be there,
zero means the photon is there.
It doesn't mean that
we have zero photons.
But sometimes, I have to
talk about the photons--
and that's what I'm
doing right now--
and zero means no
photon in this mode.
But I will remind you
of that as we go along.
So we have the two
quantum states-- one zero,
and zero one.
And let's just see what
the beam splitter is
doing to one photon in mode b.
I'm changing notation from one
line to the next in my notes.
Just give me a split second.
Yes.
So, let's use this convention.
So, just to elaborate
what I just said
is-- this convention one
zero is the direct product
of the Hilbert space
for mode b, with one
photon with the Hilbert
space of mode a,
and we have zero photons there.
And sometimes, you want
to denote the state
by putting a comma in between.
That's all the same.
So, how do we transform
the quantum state
with the beam splitter operator?
Well, we could now apply
to the quantum stage,
but we just learned how to
apply to operators, so let's
just use what we
already know, because we
can write the state like this.
And now, we want
to insert the unit.
We want to insert the
unit operator b dega b,
and now, we can use our
knowledge of the operator.
We know how this transforms.
We had this above the
transformation of the operators
b and b dega, and when we apply
b to nothing-- to no photons,
we get no photons.
So now, by taking from the
page above the transformation
or the operator b dega,
it's a linear combination
of a dega and b dega.
We find what we expect--
the photon can now
be in the same mode, or it
can appear in the other mode.
And the coefficients from the
transformation of cosine theta
minus sine theta.
And if you would send the
other state through the beam
splitter, we find the cosine
theta sine theta component.
So, since the total
probability to have a photon
is cosine square plus
sine square is unity,
we find what we expected,
but it's nice to see it.
Namely, that b conserves the
photon number-- of course,
this should have been
obvious from the outset,
because we used a Hermitian
operator, a unitary time
evolution, and that
is energy- conserving.
What happens if we
use a state which
has one photon in
each mode, and we
act on it with
the beam splitter?
Well, it gives a superposition
of the two photons
can now be in either
of the two modes,
or they can be distributed
one in each mode.
And the coefficients are because
we have two transformations,
products of sine and cosine.
Here is cosine square
plus sine square theta.
Here is a plus sine, square
root two plus square root two.
So that means if we allow one
photon to be in each mode,
it leads us actually out of the
Hilbert space of single photon
states, because we have
a certain probability
now that we have two
photons in each mode.
So, we don't want that.
So if you want to deal
with only one photon,
we should restrict our
attention, our formalism
to the states which have
nor more than one photon.
And now, if we act on those
states with beam splitters,
we don't get out of this
subspace or fill that space.
However, we also want to
omit this state because it's
more elegant to do it, but also,
if you have a single photon
state and we have a detector
which has not 100% efficiency
and we do a
measurement-- well, we
don't know if we have
the state zero one,
but we just didn't detect it,
or we had the state zero zero.
Whereas if you deal
with two states
where you always have a
photon-- exactly one photon--
and you read out your system
and you detect nothing,
well you discard
the measurement.
And then, you only
take the measurements
which have detected one photon.
So you have the ability to
deal with finite efficiencies
and losses in a very
straightforward way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The
operation of dega 1, 1
doesn't look so unitary to me.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And it is in my lecture notes.
Minus.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And it's right in
my lecture notes.
Sorry.
Sometimes, when you're talking,
explain it, build it up-- yes.
Thank you.
Other question?
Good.
So what I just said, that we
want to restrict the Hilbert
space to exactly
one photon, this
is so important for
implementations and discussions
of quantum information protocols
that it has its own name.
It's called the
dual-rail photon state.
The dual-rail
photon state space.
Exactly one photon, but the
photon can either be in mode a
or in mode b.
So this part-- this dual-rail
photon state space--
is a Hilbert space which has a
basis which is zero one and one
zero, and this is of
course a two-level system.
In this so-defined
Hilbert space,
we can have an arbitrary
state, [? psi ?] which
is-- as in any two-dimensional
Hilbert space--
it's a linear superposition
of your two base
states with coefficients
alpha and beta.
And the few of them for which
we have prepared right now
is that any possible state
of this Hilbert space
can be created from any
of the base state, that
is from zero one simply by beam
splitters and phase shifters.
When I taught this unit the last
time, I went through the proof,
but I want to make room for more
in-class discussion like we had
on Wednesday with
the clicker question,
so what I decided is I give
you the idea behind the proof,
and the formal parts
you can simply fill in
by reading about it
on the Wiki page.
So, let me just
focus on the idea.
So the proof is that
if I use some column
vector for alpha beta-- that
we can identify with the beam
splitter and the
phase shifter-- we
can identify them as
rotation operators.
This is immediate obvious if I
use the transformation on psi
by beam splitter, we learned
just a few minutes ago
how the beam splitter operator
acts on the base state.
So now, we know how it
acts on an arbitrary
linear combination.
And the matrix here
is nothing else
than the rotation
matrix with the minus
sign around the y-axis.
So that's a beam splitter.
The phase shifter is
not changing any state.
It shifts one of the states
by e to the minus i phi,
but I can sort of summarize
it by taking half of it
out as a prefector,
and then adding here
e to the i phi over two.
And this here is
immediately recognized
as the rotation matrix
around the z-axis.
Now, you may ask
what about this?
Well, this is an irrelevant
global phase factor.
If you have any state
in Hilbert space
and you change the global
phase, it doesn't matter.
Therefore, we are realizing
that the beam splitter
is a rotation around the y-axis.
It's now a definitional thing,
but we put a factor of two
here by an angle two theta,
and the phase shifter
is a rotation around the
z-axis by an angle phi.
Now, with that, we
can formulate what
is called Bloch's theorem,
that any unitary operation
of a two-dimensional
Hilbert space
can be written as a
product of rotations.
Now, let's first count an
arbitrary unitary operation
while a two by two
matrix in complex space
has eight numbers-- four real
parts, four imaginary parts.
But if the matrix
is unitary, they
are only four
independent elements--
alpha, beta, gamma, delta.
And if you parametrize the
unitary matrix with alpha,
beta, gamma, delta which is
shown in the weekly notes,
then we can write this
arbitrary unitary matrix
by a combination of an
overall phase factor.
Which is irrelevant
because it's a global phase
factor-- and then a rotation
around z, a rotation around y,
and a rotation
around the z-axis.
So, if I rephrase this
theorem in modern language,
I would say we
have a qubit which
is a two-level
system characterized
by two numbers alpha beta.
And we can do an arbitrary
operation in the Hilbert space
of the qubit, which is called
an arbitrary single qubit
operation.
So, can be performed by phase
shifters and beam splitters.
Just to make sure that this
doesn't lead to any confusion,
the phase shift which is
relevant for this Hilbert space
is a phase shift which is
relative between the two
states, and can be detected
by an interference experiment.
Those global phase shifts
cannot be detected.
There is no observable,
no procedure
to observe those-- unless you
would have a a third mode.
But then, we would
expand the Hilbert space
to three levels and
then, of course,
it's the global phase shift
in the two-dimension Hilbert
space becomes a
relative phase shift
within the three-dimension
Hilbert space.
And in modern language,
those single qubit operations
are called quantum gates.
So, all gates which
act on a single qubit
can be realized with phase
shifters and beam splitters.
Let me give you one
example for that.
In quantum computation,
quantum information science,
there is a very important
gate-- the Hadamard gate,
which is described by
a transformation which
has 1 minus 111.
And I said it can be realized
with a beam splitter and phase
shifter.
So let me just show it to you
in using our symbolic language.
So if you look at the matrix
we had derived for the beam
splitter, you realize that
we get the Hadamard gate
by aiding the phase
shifter by pi.
So, in that sense, single qubit
operations are checked off.
We know how to deal with that.
We want to now move towards
two qubit operations--
and then, it's getting
really interesting.
As you may know, you can
do any arbitrary operation
in many qubits by
just having single
and two qubit operations.
Therefore, once we know
how two qubits interact--
how photons in two
different qubits interact,
we are done-- we have
universal quantum gates.
The element I need for
two qubit operation
is the Mach-Zehnder
interferometer.
Just a side remark, I introduce
a Mach-Zehnder interferometer
here as a way to
manipulate qubits.
On the other hand,
most of you know
that interferometers for light
and interferometers for atoms
are used for some of the most
precise measurements ever done.
So, in that sense,
this shows the dual use
of the formalism I'm
introducing here.
We really use some of the
formalism and the language
we develop here for
qubit operation,
and discuss next week
the ultimate accuracy--
the fundamental
limits to the accuracy
you can get in
precision measurements
based on interferometry.
Let me just write
down the sentence
because it has a lot
of key words in it.
So the dual-rail photon
presentation of a qubit-- this
is what we have achieved so far.
So this allows us now to
discuss interferometers simply
as [INAUDIBLE] gates.
And what isn't interferometer--
an interferometer is,
in its basic [INAUDIBLE],
you have a beam splitter,
you have two paths, and then
you use another beam splitter
which recombines the two beams.
So, let me draw
two beam splitters.
These are two beam splitters.
We have an input [INAUDIBLE]
b, an input mode a.
They are sort of mixed.
Here are the two arms
of the interferometer.
And now, we create output
modes b prime and a prime.
What we have introduced
here is the beam splitter b,
and by putting the dot on the
other side, this is b dega.
Since b dega times b equals
one equals the identity,
this interferometer
is doing nothing.
If the photon
starts in mode b, it
comes out in the upper mode b.
If it starts in a, it
comes out in the mode a.
But of course, this
is just the beginning,
because we can now introduce
here an arbitrary phase shift
phi.
And now, it is an
interferometer.
Now, we can read
out with the output
the phase shift, and ultimately,
with very high precision.
I what you to appreciate that.
If we had used single qubits
in one mode-- no photon,
one photon.
I gave you many reasons
why we shouldn't do that,
but then, we would be
dealing with one mode,
and this would
actually be something
which involves two qubits.
But since our
single qubit system
is a two-level system where
the photon is here and there,
we can now send single photons
with the interferometer--
describe the interferometer
as a single qubit operation.
At least it's nice.
It allows us to
keep things simple,
and discuss things at a
very fundamental level.
So, what we want to
figure out-- what
is this interferometer doing?
So, we want to know if we
have an input state-- what
is the output state?
And the input state can now
be any arbitrary wave function
in our dual-rail Hilbert space.
So, it's always
one photon, but it
can be in a random
superposition in an arbitrary
superposition of states a and b.
Well, with the formalism
we have developed now,
it becomes very simple.
All we have to do is we have
to act with the first beam
splitter with a phase shifter,
and with a second beam splitter
onto the state.
And this is nothing else than
taking two rotation matrices
and multiplying them.
The beam splitter
we have chosen,
I said there was sort
of a phase convention
when I peeked the beam splitter.
It is a rotation by pi over 2.
This is minus pi over 2, and
the z-rotation is by minus phi.
I'm not sure if I manage to do
that, but if this is the y-axis
and we start with the qubit,
the first beam splitter
rotates it down.
Then, the rotation by z-- thus,
that-- and the second beam
splitter rotates by y.
Therefore, the
qubit is like that.
Therefore, if you count
all x's with the things
I did is-- I started
with a qubit here.
It went down like
this, like this.
So what I did is--
in the end, I simply
rotated it around the x-axis.
If you want, you can
multiply the matrices,
or you can draw block
sphere visualization.
That you say we have an
x-axis, y-axis, and z-axis.
So the z is vertical.
So, we started out with
the qubit along the z-axis.
The first one was rotation
around the y-axis.
So then, we were here.
The second operation was
rotation around the z-axis.
And then, we have to rotate
back around the y-axis, which
eventually gives this
as the final state.
So ultimately, the
product of all this
is a rotation around the x-axis.
Our interferometer--
I'm not sure
if you've ever
heard the language,
but it's really
elegant and powerful.
An interferometer with
an arbitrary phase
in this two-level Hilbert
space with this sort
of geometric interpretation
we have given,
is nothing else than a
rotation around the x-axis.
Therefore, we know immediately
the two limiting cases when
we rotate by zero,
it's sort of balanced.
Output and input are the
same, because we're not
rotating at all.
Whereas if we have a phase
shift of 180 degrees,
we swap the two qubits.
So, we swap the two
modes, and swapping modes
is an inversion of the qubit.
So that's almost trivial,
but we need this definition--
we need this knowledge to
take it to the next step.
Remember, we want
to do something
more interesting than
rotating two level systems.
We want to get two qubits,
combine them, entangle them,
and all that.
So what we need for
that is-- we have
to expand the Hilbert space.
I introduced the Mach-Zehnder
interferometer as the device
to do it.
But now, we need a way
how a second photon
from another qubit can
interact with the photon
of our first qubit.
And we want to do that
by introducing first
the non-linear Mach-Zehnder
interferometer.
I want to throw in a
non-linear element,
and then we are ready to
allow the second qubit
through the non-linear element
to manipulate the first qubit.
And then, we have
interactions between qubit.
We have two qubit gates.
Let me maybe just
deviate for my notes.
I really want to show
you what I'm doing,
and that you have it clearly
in mind where I'm aiming it.
So what we want to accomplish
is-- instead of having a phase
shifter with an externally
controlled phase,
I want to put in some
non-linear crystal-- which
has an index of refraction
which has a phase shift.
But now, the face that
the non-linear crystal
has the property, that
its index of refraction
changes when I take another
laser beam and send it through.
So, the laser beam through--
because the index of refraction
is intensity-dependent,
the green laser beam
changes index of refraction of
the non-linear crystal-- also
called Kerr medium.
And that means now,
because the blue beam
goes through the same crystal,
that the green beam controls
now the phase shift
of the blue beam.
And now, we have interacting
photons-- one photon interacts
with the second photon.
Let's work it out.
So our goal is to
develop a description
for non-linear Mach-Zehnder
interferometer.
What we need is a
non-linear medium.
So, let me just introduce
for two or three minutes
non-linear medium,
how we describe it,
and then we put in into
our interferometer.
So, in linear optics--
just to remind you,
we have a polarization on
electric dipole moment, which
is proportional to the
electric field of light,
and x i is the polarizability.
The most complicated case, it
can be polarizability tensor.
Now, this is linear.
If you want two non-linear, then
we have the linear relationship
simply as you can say the first
terminal [INAUDIBLE] expansion.
So we expand the response
of the medium in powers
of the electric field, and
we have the susceptibilities
chi 1, chi 2, chi 3, and so on.
We have already encountered
a non-linear element which
had a chi 2 susceptibility,
and these where the crystals
we put in our OPOs into our
optical parametric oscillators.
Remember, the optical
parametric oscillator
involved-- how many modes?
Three.
We had one photon, which was
broken down into two photons.
But that also means
that the reverse process
is you drive the beam-- you
drive the OPO with omega,
but the e square term creates
an electric polarization
as 2 omega.
And if you have an oscillating
polarization as 2 omega,
you create light at 2 omega.
So, I just want to remind you
that the chi square term is
what we have
already encountered.
That's not what we need for
the non-linear Mach-Zehnder
interferometer.
What we need now is
a chi 3 interaction,
which is the Kerr medium.
Because we want to realize
the following Hamiltonian.
The Hamiltonian, the Kerr
medium is also called cross--
that's cx --
cross-phase modulation.
One beam can affect the
phase of another beam,
and this is called
cross-phase modulation.
There's also
self-phase modulation--
that one laser beam changes
the index of refraction
for itself-- but here, we want
the cross-phase modulation.
So, we know that if we have a
mode, and we shift its phase,
we're not changing any photons.
So if we're in an
eigenstate of mode a
with one, two, or three photons
and we simply shift its phase,
we are diagonal in a dega
a, and the phase shift
is proportional
to prefector here.
So this Hamiltonian is simply a
phase shift for photons in mode
a, but if you now multiply
that with b dega b,
the phase shift is now
proportional to the number
of photons in mode b.
Now, we have a situation that
the phase shift from mode
a proportional to the intensity
in beam b, and vice versa.
So, I think it's self-evident
that this Hamiltonian is
sequential description
of the process we
want to introduce know.
This is the cross-phase
modulation Hamiltonian.
Isn't it much more elegant
to describe non-linear optics
with Hamiltonians than with
parametrized susceptibilities
and all that?
It's just amazing-- you
write in a few letters
and it has all the power of
the classical description--
plus extra, because it
includes quantum fluctuations
and everything.
I hope you appreciate
the power of the language
we are developing.
This is the cross-phase
modulation Hamiltonian.
And now, we want to
use this Hamiltonian
in a crystal of
lengths L Well, you
know if you have a
time-propagation operator,
you put the Hamiltonian in the
exponent and multiply with t,
but for propagating laser
beam, t and L are related,
so this is now the
unitary transformation
if you propagate
through that crystal.
We are now defining
that by saying
we have this non-linear
susceptibility,
things will be proportional
to the links L,
and then we have the
operator a dega a, b dega b.
And let me choose for
the following discussion
that the links are
chosen, such that-- when
multiplied with a
non-linear susceptibility,
we get a phase shift of pi.
Now, we are ready
to describe what
happens when we
have a Kerr medium,
and we have two input modes.
So, let's write down the
table of possible combinations
and operations.
Well, when we act on the
vacuum, we get nothing.
What happens when we have
one photon in one mode?
What happens to that photon?
Well, the extra
phase shift coming
from cross-phase
modulation is zero,
because we have no photon in
one of the modes, and a dega a
or b dega b acting on
this mode gives zero.
Therefore, as long as
we have only one photon,
we have no phase shift.
The exponential factor
is one, and we simply
reproduce the original state.
So, the only non-trivial
situation by construction
is when we have one
photon in each mode,
and then we get the matrix
element e to the ikl.
And we adjusted the
lengths of the crystal
that this is just minus one.
In other words, in
this Hilbert space,
we get a phase shift of pi--
we get a minus sign when
we have one photon in each mode.
That's all what
this medium does.
And if you ever
thought about it--
how to deal with this
situation-- that when
I said there is one photon
which provides a phase
shift to the other photon.
But the other photon is
also providing a phase shift
to the first photon.
So you may wonder.
When you have a combined
state of the two,
how do you deal that
one photon shifts
the other photon,
and vice versa?
But when you apply
the operator, you
don't even have
to think about it.
You see that the operator
for the combined Hilbert
space of the two photons
gives you a phase shift of pi.
It's not pi for one photon
times pi for the other one--
it's pi for the
whole quantum state.
Any questions?
We have a Kerr
medium, which means
we are ready now to put it
into our interferometer.
I'm doing at this
time-- insert picture.
This is what you want to do now.
We have now three
modes of light.
You would say, hey-- a
qubit, each qubit is two.
What is it-- is it
one and a half qubit?
Yes, it is-- but we extended
two cubits in a moment.
So what we simply
have right now is
we have the mode c-- which
controls the non-linear medium,
and we have what we
have already discussed.
Our interferometer
with a phase shifter,
which is now the Kerr medium.
So I think even
without doing any math,
we know that by construction,
when we have no photons in c,
that the modes a prime b prime
transform-- become a and b,
because we have a balance
interferometer which
is the identity transformation,
unless we have a phase shift.
But when we have one photon in
state c, then we actually swap.
So, that's pretty cool.
A single photon in mode c will
redirect the photon from ab
to ba.
So that's how one
photon in mode c
controls what happens
to the photon in ab.
If you want a general
description of that,
we obtain the output
state from the input state
by using the matrix b.
This was our interferometer
based on two beam splitters.
It involved mode a and b.
But now, we throw in
the phase shifter,
which is our Kerr operator--
our non-linear phase
shifter with b and c.
This new addition to
the interferometer
is described by e to the i,
non-linear susceptibility L,
b dega b, c dega c.
Let me give you one
intermediate result.
We have now beam
splitters on either side.
And that leads us
to an expression.
While the beam splitters
do nothing to the mode c,
but the beam splitters
transform the modes
in linear combinations.
And if you do some tedious
rearrangement of terms--
more details are
given in the Wiki--
you find that the
essential result is now
the operator, which we get is
a dega b minus b dega a over 2.
I'm not giving you the
non-essential terms,
which are just phase
shifts-- global phase shifts.
So, let me write it
down in blue here.
This is just the result of
the operator manipulation.
If I would cover
that-- what is that?
Do you remember a dega b minus
b dega a in the exponent?
It's a beam splitter.
And the beam splitter--
the beam splitter
matrix was sine
theta cosine theta.
So we had a theta here.
Now, you realize that this
non-linear Mach-Zehnder
interferometer, the
three optical elements
can be replaced by simply a
single-beam splitter for mode
a and b, but the angle
theta of the beam splitter
is now controlled by the
photon field in state c.
In other words, we have
now a beam splitter.
I told you that a
beam splitter is
nothing else than a
rotation around the y-axis.
So now, this non-linear
Mach-Zehnder interferometer
is simply a beam
splitter with a rotation
angle given by this term.
Any questions?
This is a situation we
just had, and we can now
get to two qubits by simply
adding one more rail.
Remember, two rails with exactly
one photon in it is a qubit.
So now, we have a qubit here,
and we have a qubit there.
And you see immediately
one way how the upper qubit
x on the lower qubit--
if the lower qubit has
a photon in state c, it
flips the other qubit.
But if the upper qubit
has a photon in d,
it doesn't do anything
to the lower qubit.
Now, we have a
two-qubit operation.
This is shown here.
But what I want to discuss
now is the situation
when we throw in one
more beam splitter,
and this beam splitter
acts on the upper qubit.
Well-- isn't it
great how quickly
we go from simple
elements to something
which looks quite sophisticated?
So, this device now is
a single optical device
which can entangle qubits,
which leads to entanglement.
And actually, entanglement
is our next big topic
we want to talk about--
entanglement between particles,
entanglement between photons.
And by introducing the
Mach-Zehnder interferometer,
I was actually building
up the situation,
which is extremely
simple elements which
lead to entanglement.
We have everything
for the description--
each of those
elements is described
by a matrix which
we have developed.
Therefore, by just
multiplying those matrices,
you find immediately how
this whole device is now
manipulated into qubits.
So, if you want, you
can just take the crank,
use what we have already
done, and crank out
the result for it.
Now I wish I had
a bigger screen,
because I want to describe
what's going on for you.
What I want to
discuss with you now
is what happens when
we take this device,
and we use exactly the
states 0,1 0,1 at the input
as I indicated.
In terms of qubit
language, I say
that the first
qubit is in spin-up,
and the lower qubit
is also in spin-up.
Spin-down would mean
that the single photon
is in the other state.
Our two-level system--
our dual-rail single qubit
two-level system is the
photon can be either
in one of those states.
This one, we call spin-up--
this one, we call spin-down.
What I want to
discuss with you now,
what happens when we start
with this symmetric input
up-up, which means 0,1 0,1.
And since I don't want to
scroll up and down so often,
everything is trivial
beam splitters,
except for the situation when
we have one photon each here,
and then the Kerr medium
gives us a minus sign.
So that's what I want to put in.
Remember, I want to
develop the physics
in one, two, three
temporal steps.
The first temporal step is
simply two beam splitters,
and this is shown here.
We start out-- and now
we have beam splitter
for the upper qubit, beam
splitter for the lower qubit.
And well, by just
multiplying it out,
we are now obtaining
this summation state
for the four different modes.
And I'm dropping here
factors of square root--
or you can collect them
at the end, if you want.
And I said the only
interesting situation
is where we have two
photons-- one each in the two
middle modes, because now, the
Kerr medium kicks in and gives
us a minus sign.
Now, you can show by inspection
that if you now apply the beam
splitter to modes
a and b, you take
1, 0 into a linear
combination of 1 and 1,
but the beam splitter is only
acting on the last two numbers
here.
Then you obtain a state
which looks very simple.
So this is the output
state of the device.
Any questions?
And this output state is--
if I use the spin language,
it's an entangled state.
So now, you have
one simple example
how just using linear
optics, very simple elements
you can start with one
photon here, one photon here,
a simple product state,
and what comes out
is an entangled state.
Questions?
Let me tell you what I'm
not telling you-- namely,
the Wiki developed by
a professor [INAUDIBLE]
has now a wonderful section on
a famous quantum algorithm--
the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm.
Pretty much using the
elements we discuss,
you can now realize the
Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm,
which is one of the
famous algorithms where
quantum logic--
quantum computation is
faster and more efficient
than classical computation.
I decided not to present
it to you, because it just
leads to an even more
complicated diagram and more
formulae.
You should just sit back and
slowly read it by yourself.
There is no new
idea introduced--
it's just the concepts
we have discussed
can lead to very
powerful algorithms.
What I want to rather do is-- I
want to continue our discussion
and now talk about the object
we have encountered here--
namely, entangled states.
But if you have any
questions, if you
want me to explain anything
more about the single qubit
manipulation, the
dual-rail photon state,
I would be happy to do that.
Our next chapter is
on entangled photons,
and what we can accomplish
in the next 10 or 15 minutes
is mainly a definition and
some of the properties.
What we will do
next week is we will
talk about how we measure
entanglement-- you already
had one homework assignment
where you discussed one
way to measure
entanglement, but there
are others which we want
to discuss next week.
I also want to show you next
week how entanglement leads
to the Einstein-Podolsky-Rosen
paradox and Bell's
inequalities.
And eventually, I
want to show you
how you can entangle
not only photons,
but how you can entangle atoms.
But that's an outlook.
I think, first of all,
we want to understand
what is entanglement.
Entanglement is-- let me
first [? motivate ?] it.
Many people regard entanglement
as the most quantum
essence you can find.
Well, there's
always a discussion,
but it's really quantum.
Some people would say
waves are quantum.
But often, we find
quantum systems--
very famously, Bose-Einstein
condensates, which really
behave like
electromagnetic waves.
They can be split.
They can interfere.
But Bose-Einstein condensates
are so big, have so many atoms
that you hardly ever encounter
quantum fluctuations.
You're really in the classical
limit of matter waves,
and I would actually
say this is maybe not
at the heart of
quantum mechanics.
While it's nice,
it's powerful, it's
important-- but this is not
really the new feature which
quantum mechanics has
shown us in nature.
You would say-- well,
what else is quantum?
Maybe certain
quantum fluctuations
going down to single
photons, and I
would agree that's
a quantization
of the electromagnetic field.
That's much more quantum than
having millions of condensates,
millions of condensed
atoms in one single wave.
But what I would say
is even more quantum
than the single photon
is the entanglement.
Entanglement is sort of
pure quantum mechanics.
With single photons, you
can still use intuition.
But with entanglement,
that is really bizarre.
This is really- I
hate the word, but let
me use it-- this is sort
of pure quantum weirdness.
And there are people who have
spent most of their career
until now to just show the
weirdness of quantum mechanics,
and showing to what peculiar
phenomena entanglement leads.
So entanglement has really
lead to a lot of-- I
should be careful with the
word surprising-- surprising
always means you didn't
have enough imagination
to think about it, but yes,
I would say-- really truly
unanticipated, and in that
sense, surprising developments.
Entanglement is, therefore,
for me, the most quantum
aspect of quantum mechanics.
It was through the
Einstein-Podolsky-Rosen
argument-- it was actually
in the '30s who argued--
Einstein-Podolsky-Rosen were
really the first--
this was almost 5
or 10 years after the
development of quantum
mechanics.
But it was
Einstein-Podolsky-Rosen
who looked at the properties
of entangled states.
This famous experiment
where you have something
entangled in position
and momentum space.
And then,
Einstein-Podolsky-Rosen
found a paradox,
and their conclusion
was that the properties
of entangled states
implies that quantum
mechanic is not
compete-- is not a complete
description of the word.
Well, we don't any longer
share this opinion.
It was John Bell and others who
said that entanglement really
exemplifies that quantum
mechanical correlations go
beyond classical mechanics--
go beyond the classic picture.
Therefore, you can say
if you have a quantum
system like a
Bose-Einstein condensate,
where you have end
particles doing
in unison what
one particle does.
This is sort of like the
laser where many photons do
what one photon does--
but it fits very, very
well into the concept of
classical probabilities
and an intuitive understanding
of why many particles do
what one particle does.
But if the particles
are entangled,
that's almost like you
turbo-charge your system.
Your system has now more
oomph, more power in it.
And this is shown that it
has extra correlation-- there
is something extra in
it, which you would never
get from any classical limit.
And this extra oomph,
this extra power
turns out to be a real resource.
So, entanglement-- this extra
correlation-- is a resource.
And resource means it's
good for something.
It enables teleportation.
Remember when we talked about
the teleportation scheme--
Alice and Bob could only
teleport a quantum state
because they shared
entangled photons.
It was this entangled state
which Alice manipulated
with a measurement,
and Bob used this half
of the entangled state to
recreate the original state.
So, it's the engine
[INAUDIBLE] up
behind teleportation in the
world of quantum computation.
The exponential speedup
of quantum computers
versus classical computers
in quantum algorithms
is due to the
entanglement, which
we can put into
a quantum system.
And eventually,
next week, you will
see that if you have
an atom interferometer
with entangled states,
we can operate it
at a precision which is
better than short noise.
So in other words, you use laser
light to measure something,
and you're limited by
the fundamental noise
limit of classical physics.
Now, you entangle
your laser beam
and you get higher
precision out of it.
So this shows that entanglement
is a very special resource.
It's very precious,
very powerful
and can extend what
physics can do.
So, let's define it.
I'm not describing
to you entanglement
in the most generous situation.
If you talk about
many modes-- if you
talk about not just pure states,
but statistical operators--
it can become quite involved.
I'd rather start with the
simple situation, which
for conceptual discussions is
also the most important one.
I restrict our focus
now on two modes.
I want to ask if you have two
modes a-- actually, two modes
means two subsystems here.
If you have two
subsystems a and b--
let me tell you what
entanglement is not,
and then I make
it the definition.
There wouldn't be
anything special
if you have a system which
has two parts a and b.
The global system is psi ab.
But if your system
would simply factorize
into a wave function
of subsystem a,
direct product with
subsystem b, and this here
is the tensor product.
Then, there would be
nothing special going on
between subsystem
a and subsystem b--
and this is non-entangled.
Everything else is entangled.
So, this is our definition.
When we have two
separate systems a and b,
we call this situation the
total system bipartite.
So, a bipartite state which has
sort of half of it in system a,
half of it in system b.
We need those two
different systems--
it's a composite
system a plus b.
And this state is entangled-- if
and only if you cannot find two
states psi a and psi b,
such that the state can be
factorized.
We need a few examples
to fully comprehend
this discussion-- what
systems a and b qualify.
What does it mean if there
does not exist any combination?
So, let me give you
some examples now,
and then I think we stop.
If you have the 0, 0
state, photons in two mode,
we can factorize it-- and
this is not entangled.
If you have a state which
is 0, 0 plus 1, 1-- well,
you cannot write it as a product
of one state times another
state.
This is entangled.
Well, if you take the following
state-- Is that entangled
or not?
I've written it as a
sum of four states,
but if you just stare at
it for a split second,
you realize you can just write
it as a product of two states.
It's just a product
of 0, 1 with 0, 1.
So, a state is not entangled
if you can write it
as a linear superposition
of those states.
The definition of
entanglement is--
if you try hard
and hard and hard,
and there doesn't exist any
product state decomposition,
then it is entangled.
So, that was easy.
If you use a state like-- let
me just leave the 1, 1 out.
What about this one?
Well, you can try as
hard as you want--
you will not find
the decomposition.
So eventually,
when I say you have
to try hard to
find decomposition,
maybe what we want
is we want to apply
some operator or some
procedure to this state,
and get the answer, yes-no.
This naturally asks for
question-- how in general can
we measure if a state
is entangled or not?
But this is something
we'll discuss next week.
So let me just conclude
with the following.
I'm focusing here and for pretty
much all of this cause when
we talk about entanglement,
about pure states.
If you have decoherence--
if you have the transition
from pure states to
density matrices--
it gets much more involved
to talk about entanglement
and measure entanglement.
But at least the
basic definition
can still be maintained
for statistical operators.
If you describe the system--
the total system by one
statistical operator-- the
system is not entangled.
If the statistical
operator can be broken up
into a direct tensor product
of statistical operator
for system a and system b.
Otherwise, the
system is entangled.
So the basic definition
can be generalized
to density matrices,
but a lot of things
become much, much more messy
if you don't have pure states.
Any last-minute questions?
See you on Monday.